People in Silicon Valley are starting to worry about the drop-off in tech IPOs.
And here's why.
Investors that bet on young companies rely on IPOs to make their money back.
They can't do that.
They may stop writing checks to fund the next Google or Facebook.
This is happening already.
The amount of money invested in start-ups has fallen from a peak about six months ago.
So why are we in this IPO desert?
For one, about half the tech companies that went public in the US since 2010...
...are trading below their IPO price.
Just look at Twitter or GoPro.
It's hard to sell investors on new stocks...
...when too many of them got burned betting on the last IPOs.
And two, there's a big expectations gap.
There are more than 150 unicorns.
That's Silicon Valley jargon for a start-up valued at a billion dollars or more.
Many of these companies will be worth far less if they tried to go public now.
So many of them are waiting and waiting, to try to improve their business...
...and IPO at a higher price.
These unicorns could be right to wait,...
...or they could run out of money waiting for the perfect time to go public.